suicide is a major issue and especially
in nevada and intermountain healthcare
the sponsors of this next segment are
here to help with the defensive line
let's welcome kerry blancas with
intermountain healthcare and chris
thomas the co-founder of the defensive
line welcome you guys thank you welcome
thank you carol start with you can you
break down some of the numbers that
we're facing here in nevada the numbers
are pretty sobering here in nevada
when you look at the statistics of
nevada against the united states at
large across the board we are above
average for the suicide rates in the
state
whether whether we're talking about race
or ethnicity
age population we're there we're always
above the state the
federal rates and we want to change that
we don't we don't like those numbers at
all this is not a good thing and chris
with the defensive line you guys are
doing wonderful things tell us more
about the organization especially how
everything started for you guys yeah so
it started with our daughter ella dying
by suicide january 23rd of 2018. so we
wanted to find a way to turn up pain
into purpose and so we created an
organization that we have a vision where
no young person of color dies by suicide
by transforming the way we talk and
communicate about mental health so we go
into schools talk about suicide warnings
risks people who are at risk and we give
them tools and resources to help them
stay alive that's just a great thing you
guys are doing and your son has a great
connection to our city tell everyone who
your son is yes solomon thomas he was
number 92 for the raiders and he had a
really good year helping the raiders get
into the playoffs unfortunately he fell
short but now he's in new york with the
gym we miss him already
all right we miss him
yeah as well yes yes so how did the
partnership between the two of you guys
come together then chris has reached out
to our organization and
improving mental well-being is a vital
aim of intermountain healthcare and it's
something that we want to participate
with community partners like chris's
organization and other organizations to
tackle this problem that is beyond any
one of us being able to improve the
outcomes
chris what would you say to someone
that's watching right now that is in
need and needs some help but maybe
they're afraid to make that call or
they're afraid to talk somebody maybe
there's some shame behind it what would
you say to someone that's watching right
now i say it's important that we
normalize the conversation we talk about
the importance of mental health mental
well-being it's not physical or mental
health it's whole health and we got to
make sure we look at this for the signs
of people who are who are struggling and
make sure you have london ear to listen
to them make sure you lend them to the
right areas like 741 separate one the
text line or the
800-825-525-8275 the talk number to get
them to come on and get the resources
they need and then kerry what advice
would you give to someone who thinks
they have a friend or someone that might
be in trouble and need some help what
advice would you give to them i think
chris brought up some really good
resources and the answer is there's no
wrong advice
listen is the number one thing that any
one person can do you don't have to be
an expert in assisting somebody you can
help them get to the resources that they
need and what's the text line again for
741 cent for one the great thing about
the text line you don't have to be at
risk if you want to get some resources
you want to get some support
understanding how to support somebody
you can call that number they'll walk
you through how to get it it's a
fountain of information yes absolutely
thank you guys so much for joining us
and saving lives now which is such a
special thing thank you so much youtube
we appreciate it thank you very much now
a big thank you to intermountain
healthcare for sponsoring this segment
for more details visit
thedefenseofline.org
las vegas now we will be right back